My name is Aevin Jude Dugas and I am the world record holder for the world's largest Afro.
Guinness World Records ended up contacting me and asking me to measure it.
And the first time, I think I sent a video and it wasn't really that clear,...
...so I ended up sending them measurements. And now, here I am.
When my hair is on an Afro, it is problematic because when I'm driving, I can't see,...
...so that's a problem. One time, I slammed my hair in the car door getting in.
It gets caught in clubs. It might get caught in someone's drink.
It gets caught in my earrings a lot and, you know, that causes problems.
It tends to hook on things like trees and stuff when I'm walking by...
...when other people don't have their problem.
So, it can be kind of problematic, but I still wouldn't change a thing about it.